I would rather have a church that
becomes condensed and and and much
smaller but what you have left with the
remnants are people who are really on
fire with the faith really believe in it
and so I say if that's fine trim the fat
[Music]
hey hey and welcome this is the Ben
Shapiro show Sunday special will be
joined momentarily by the man more dour
than I Matt Walsh of The Daily wire but
first let's talk about your impending
death Tory will get into issues of
heaven and hell here but I'm just
talking about like why your family's
gonna do if you plotz
getting life insurance can feel like
assembling the world's worst jigsaw
puzzle it is confusing it takes forever
and when you're finally done it doesn't
even look cool but if you have a
mortgage or kids or anybody who depends
on your income it is a puzzle that you
need to solve and policy genius can help
you do it policy genius is the easy way
to get life insurance in just two
minutes you can compare quotes from top
insurers and find the best policy for
you when you apply online the advisors
at policy genius
will handle all the red tape for you
they'll even negotiate your rate with
the insurance company no commission
sales agents no hidden fees just helpful
advice and personalized service and
policy genius doesn't just do life
insurance they also do home insurance
and auto insurance and disability
insurance they're your one-stop-shop for
financial protection so if you find life
insurance puzzling head on over to
policy genius com in two minutes you can
compare quotes find the right policy
save up to 40% doing it being an adult
don't waste time ago two policy genius
right now get the life insurance for
that way if your plots they don't have
to bury you in a pauper's grave policy
genius the easy way to compare and buy
life insurance go check it out right now
it only takes a couple of minutes so be
a responsible human find that right
policy save up to 40% doing a policy
genius the easy way to compare and buy
life insurance all right Matt Walsh
thanks so much for joining the Ben
Shapiro show Sunday special thanks for
having me
I mean not that you had much of a choice
in this I mean yeah I know I work here I
feel like you're scraping the bottom of
the barrel a little bit having me on
here but I mean I appreciate okay well
for those of us who don't know anything
about your background except that you
sit in cards and have a beard in our
dowel or
what once your what's your background
how did you get to the point where you
get paid to sit in cars and write
columns and be Dow lord have a beard you
know it's it's it's a really
uninteresting story but I think I think
it began with I was I was kind of a
terrible student now so I think people
ask me all the time did you go to
college and what did you go to college
for did you go to college for singing
cars and yet and screaming into a phone
and the answer is no you know I didn't
go to college I was a pretty bad student
barely graduated high school wonder why
I'm mentioning all this but it's true
in fact I didn't even know that I was
going to graduate high school until the
way that I found out is I went to the
the graduation rehearsal which for some
reason you have to rehearse walking
across the stage and I knew that if I
went to the rehearsal and my name was on
a seat so I had an assigned seat that
I'm gonna graduate and I'm gonna get to
and so it was and so that's three and I
kind of bounced around for a while but I
knew that I I wanted to somehow sort of
be engaged in the conversation on a
public level I didn't really know how to
go about doing that so I figured maybe
one way is to get into radio which is
what I did for about seven years I got
into just music radio as a music DJ and
and making about seventeen thousand
dollars a year doing that basically
poverty wages and at some point I
realized that this is not you know it's
it's hard to climb your way up in
terrestrial radio these days so you had
to get online and I started a website
called the Matt Walsh blog which was
very creatively titled and after about
six months it just kind of took off and
I had you know it's getting a couple
million readers a month and that's the
story I told you it wasn't interesting
so you're known for not only being very
caustic but obviously being very
religious so what is your religious
background get into religion a little
bit more deeply a little bit later in
the in the show but what's your
religious background what's your belief
system yeah I'm Catholic so I grew up
very Catholic very conservative Catholic
I've got you know five brothers and
sisters and my one of my sisters is a
nun now so that's the kind of Catholic
family that we have and but I grew up in
a very kind of liberal area I go into
public school so you had to you know
your parents had to instill in you the
ability to defend not just the ability
to defend your beliefs but also the
willingness and and sort of finding joy
and that argument so I think that's kind
of where I got it from and how did all
of this impact on your politics so
you're a conservative obviously you are
not a super pro-trump conservative
during 2016 so how does your worldview
shape your political views well you know
for me the the the first objective or
for everyone is to is to get to heaven
right that's that's the first objective
is our is our spiritual fulfill
so that to me is is number one before
you get to to politics or anything like
that and this is you know one of the
problems I see in the conservative
movement now is I don't it's it seems
like it's not really grounded in
anything like maybe it used to be
grounded in those deeper kind of
spiritual moral truths so I think it's
got to be kind of ground ground up from
there what are your what do you what are
your fundamental beliefs like what and
that is why are we here what's the point
of life what's the point of any of this
I think those are the questions you have
to be able to answer and then once you
can answer those questions then you sort
of build your political framework on top
of that so from a religious point of
view and you say that the goal is to get
to heaven
are you a belief based person I mean is
it is it that you believe in Christ and
therefore you go to heaven or is it a
work space thing because obviously this
is sort of a differentiator between
Judaism and Christianity and some
iterations yeah I think well and I don't
mean to dismiss like 500 years of
fighting between Protestants and
Catholics but I kind of think that the
at least between Protestants and
Catholics the works verse faiths
dichotomy it's it's kind of a
misunderstanding because I think we
actually generally agree in that I
certainly don't believe that the whole
point of life is just to intellectually
assent to the proposition that Jesus
Christ is Lord and and there is a God
and you know so people will say that all
you have to do is believe in Jesus or
you have to do is believe in God I I
definitely don't believe that but if we
want to talk about faith okay well you
have to put your faith in God that is
more than an intellectual exercise that
is something that you do with your whole
life and your whole mind and soul and
body that you're investing yourself in
this belief and that that includes works
but it's not as though you know you give
a certain amount to charity and you help
old ladies across the street and you go
to heaven it's not as simple as that
so it's kind of a it's kind of a
combination between the way that I see
it is it's sort of like you know if if
you if you if God is a is a is a bridge
into into heaven
to the afterlife you can't just walk up
to the bridge and say yes I believe that
the bridge is there I assent to the
existence of the bridge and then just go
and sit on the other side of the bridge
and not cross it you actually have to
trust the bridge and with your own
effort walk across it over the abyss and
so I think it's sort of that's what
faith is so when it comes to your view
of the afterlife what what cultivated
that what where do you where do you get
your view of heaven what do you think
heaven looks like and what makes you
believe that there is something after we
die well I you know I get it from my for
my faith primarily but of course you
know when you read the Bible there isn't
a lot of in terms of a description of
what the afterlife is actually going to
look like and and and everything that it
entails so you know I think if you look
at if you look at you have to look at
Christian philosophy through the ages
and how they've sort of developed this
idea one for me in terms of my thinking
about the afterlife for me the most
influential thing that I've read besides
the Bible would be CS Lewis Great
Divorce I don't know if you've read that
I
I don't know how biblical it really is
but he what I like about what in that
book is what he does is he he's able to
really illustrate how it is that a
person might choose hell instead of
heaven because the only thing that makes
sense for me in terms of Hell is well
it's not so much that God sends you
there even if you really want to go to
heaven God says no you know you did this
you did that that was wrong and now you
have to go roast in the eternal fires
for 50 trillion years and then you
haven't even started at that point so
that's him that sort of version has
never really made sense to me what does
make sense and what you'll hear
Christians say a lot is well no God
doesn't send you to hell you choose it
okay
well alright then it seems more just but
what does it mean to choose hell how
could anyone ever choose hell when they
know that eternal joy is on offer and
anyway in the book a great divorce I
think it does a good job of showing what
that might sort of look like or why a
person might actually choose hell
rather than heaven and it all comes from
are you interested are you able to find
joy outside of yourself or have you only
ever been able to figure out how to
pursue your own interests and if that's
what it is if you're only interested in
yourself then God will say okay well you
want yourself that's all you want that's
all you love and have yourself in
isolation for eternity that's what you
want yeah there's a tell me you to tell
that sort of says something similar then
tell me you detail is that there's a
bunch of rabbis it's the afterlife
there's a bunch of lab rabbis trying to
figure out what's heaven and what's Hell
and basically hell is a bunch of people
who are sitting around a table and
there's these amazing foods that are on
the table and all that is in front of
people are spoons that are too long for
them to actually take the spoon and put
it in the food and get it's their mouth
it's too long they just can't reach it
the spoon is too lengthy and heaven is
they've is the people have realized that
the spoon is too long for their own
mouth so they're feeding each other so
it's the exact same thing but the idea
is that the perspective has shifted I'm
what's important right it's let's look
it's being able to look beyond yourself
and so the question I always ask myself
and I was talking about some people my
family about this recently is you know
is it is it possible for someone who
loves anyone to go to hell even if you
have someone who didn't you know didn't
really believe in God wasn't religious
but let's say they really did love their
wife and they really did love their
child not just that emotional affection
but actually love them is it is it
possible even possible metaphysically
for that person to go to hell
considering that they have love in them
and if hell is a place where no love can
be then how could that person be there
and I guess it seems to me that if you
figure out how to love anyone outside of
yourself during your life then I think
that's something God can take and work
with and those are little embers of
something that he can ignite into a fire
and a good sense so that's sort of the
objective of life is to is to love it
love and do what you will is agustin I
think so that is a very very often I
hear you know Christians say things like
God is love and the Jew and me goes well
he's a little more than that what's it
what's your take on the these sort of
boiling down of Christianity to the to
the sort of trope that God is love what
does that mean and what is that supposed
to mean or is there something beyond
that I think that that statement is only
problematic in our society because we
have such a absurd view of what love is
a shallow view I should say we think of
love as just an emotional attachment and
so very often when we say we love
someone it's really about us we do what
we love about them we love about them is
how they make us feel when we're with
them but that's not actually what love
is love is is it was Aquinas that the
love is willing the good of the other
that's what it means to love someone's
very kind of simple way of looking at if
you really want what is best for them
in every sense spiritually as well and
you're going to work as much as you can
to bring that it help them bring it
about in their own life and then you
love them and so if we think of love and
in that sense
number one is a choice as a force of
will
then I think God is love kind of works
although I although I think maybe it's
just better to say God is all loving
maybe when you say God is love it just
becomes sort of Kentucky's dad right
exactly love is God it becomes a sort of
pantheistic thing of we're all we are
all God ourselves if we love and just
weird stuff so thank God God is loving
is the best way of putting it I think
yeah certainly in the Jewish view when
it comes to the notion of love being
giving that's that's actually embedded
in the Hebrew of Ahava Havas the Hebrew
word for love and have whether the root
of hey and bet means gift so it's
actually embedded in the word Ahava so
when it comes to you know you see you
write a lot about politics how do you
separate out talking about religion from
talking about politics when should you
speak in sort of a religious moral sense
and when should you speak in a kind of a
secular sense when when you're trying to
make an argument yeah that's a that's a
good question as a balance I am still
struggling to strike myself I can't say
that I always do the best job of it but
I do know that when it comes to these
great moral issues in our society like
abortion marry
you know gender that we have to be able
to engage on those issues without
throwing the Bible at people especially
if we're talking to people who don't
believe in the Bible because when you
try to go the biblical route you're
talking someone doesn't believe in it
well then you just put an extra step in
your way which is first you have to get
them to believe the Bible which is a
whole different conversation and a
pretty difficult one so I think that
that's not the route and instead you
have to talk about these funds natural
law these fundamental moral truths so
you have to try to connect with them on
and also logic and reason it's something
like I always cringe when I hear when
the topic is something like
transgenderism and I hear a Christian
say you know quote Genesis or something
and say well God male and female he
created them I say yes it's true but we
don't even you don't need to bring
Genesis into this it is a very basic
logical distinction between you got many
are women here men have penises
so you know you should be able to
explain that without quoting Genesis and
you also give I think your listener an
easy out because then they're going to
say oh you're just tossing the Bible I
mean I'm not going to listen to that or
they'll say that well you know you only
disagree with abortion because you're
Christian are you only you're only
saying that because you're Christian
wouldn't really know even if I was not a
Christian I still would say it's not ok
to kill babies you know so I think that
on that level we have to be able to
connect without religion although at the
same time within the religions certainly
within Christianity there are a lot of
Christians who are very confused on
these issues and who think that it's ok
to be a Christian and endorse the
killing of babies and in that case ok
now you're gonna start throw-in
scripture at them and now you're really
come in with the you know the holy now
it's a holy war because this is someone
that already supposedly agrees with the
basic religious premise what do you
think has happened to religious
leadership generally so I know that a
lot of religious people you do it I do
it we sort of lament the fall of
religious leadership the feel that
churches and synagogues are emptying out
in many ways that too many religious
leaders have decided to give sort of
rote
general statements about the Bible
rather than some of the hard-nosed
truths of the Bible what do you think
the religious community is doing wrong
what can we do better I could say
certainly with Christians what are they
doing wrong let's I mean that's a
two-hour conversation alone right there
I I think that may be the the best way
to condense it is to say that church is
a church leadership they're trying too
much to look like secular society and
they're thinking that that's the way to
bring people in and you see that even
when you go to a lot of Christians
suppose a church services and you walk
in and you might not even know that
you're integer in fact I remember a few
years ago I went with my wife when we
were living in Kentucky and there was
this weird structure that had been built
near our house we had no idea what was
what it was we thought it was a mall it
was our best guess and so we went one
Sunday after our after we went to a real
church we said let's you know let's go
check out this mall we walk in and we're
looking around were a little bit
confused and then we realized it about
ten minutes that it's actually a church
so you shouldn't be that way that's
that's this is a church that is trying
to blend in with the world as Christians
would put it but then once you do that
it's like what's the point what are you
offering if if if you're a ping secular
society and you're offering secular
platitudes and secular lessons and
you're giving motivational speeches and
giving financial advice and all of these
things you get in sermons these days
well somebody wants that well then why
why would they even go to a church just
go to a Tony Robbins seminar go to watch
Oprah go to an actual mall I mean go to
any go walk walk on a beach I mean
there's so many other things you could
do if you just want sort of non
religious secular enjoyment and and
encouragement so you have to give people
something different because that's what
people are hungry for it they we're all
living in this secular society none of
us are happy with it I'm especially
unhappy with with everything but you
know everyone's a little bit unhappy at
least and and so we're looking for
something different something
substantive and so religion should be
there to offer that thing
and I would say that from my experience
I go to a Latin Mass Church which is the
super you know crazy traditional women
where have head coverings and and all of
that kind of stuff and it's a very young
church I mean there are a lot of young
people in there young families and it's
just energetic and everything whereas if
you go to a Catholic Church where
they're doing the you know they're doing
the secular choir and they're doing all
that and you walk in it's just there of
their five or six old board baby boomers
sitting in the pews yawning and it's
just it's not working let's do a little
bit of free association here so I'm
gonna give you a phrase and you give me
your immediate response to this so let's
start with President Donald Trump you
know I think that just give you one word
please
okay you know what I I think that I
obviously didn't support Donald Trump
during the primaries and people asked me
I'm sure they ask you all the time well
do you regret that or have you seen how
wrong you were
and my answer is no I was not wrong I
was right as usual my point about Donald
Trump well I never thought that he was
gonna start World War three or any this
crazy stuff my concern about Trump was
the effect he would have on the
conservative movement and that he would
cause a lot of conservatives to spend a
lot of time defending every little thing
that he does even things that are
indefensible or little petty things that
just don't need to be defended and I was
concerned that that would happen
and and that's what the conservative
movement would become and that is what
it has become so no I don't I don't
think I was wrong now
yeah he's done some good things we got
the Supreme Court justices although
honestly the Supreme Court justices he
gave us any of the Republicans would've
given us those two guys so okay that's
fine though and Plus you give him a Cana
more credit than I do Trump for those
things and he's done a couple of other
good things I just think I don't know I
I hear conservatives all even some
former
Trump errs which I never loved that
label but who say oh I was totally wrong
and I've been totally proven wrong he's
been great and I I don't believe them I
don't think they really think that I
think they're just saying that because
it's the popular thing to say I think we
all know that there are certain aspects
of Trump that have been pretty
disastrous and we all know that so I
don't know why we're pretending
otherwise but as I said he has he's also
done some good things and what I'll say
this is what I've been saying about
Trump for a long time is that the great
thing about Trump is that he is willing
to say things that a lot of Republicans
or any other Republican is not willing
to say the problem is that a lot of
those things he's willing to say are
stupid but if you can get him like if
you write him a speech like a State of
the Union speech and you put a lot of
great stuff in there about Israel you
put a lot of great stuff in there about
the about abortion he'll say that stuff
and those are things what he said in
State of the Union address is about the
topic of abortion no Republican speaks
like certainly no Republican president
has spoken that way so he's willing to
do that and that is where he's really
useful but that only really comes out
when he's sticking to the script
and when he's got people helping him and
sort of guiding him I think when he's
just off on his own doing his own thing
that he goes off on all these tangents
that are you know I'm not crying about
though I just find them useless and
petty and there are more important
things we talking about you know you and
I voted the same way I think in the same
in the last election which was not at
all at the top of the ticket right you
didn't go to the top so you know what my
take was that there were three things I
was afraid of if Trump were to win one
was that he would not govern
conservatively because he'd been all
over the place in his statements he's
governed more conservatively than I
thought
second was the same thing that you were
worried about was this kind of soul suck
of the Republican Party where the party
starts defending every little thing that
he does or starts seeing him as a
thought leader and defending bad ideas
that he puts out there I think is about
half true because I think that very few
people in the actual Republican Party
see him as a thought leader I think a
lot of people see him more as a vessel
for their policy preferences or for
smacking the left and then the third
thing I was worried about was him
poisoning the well with young people
which obviously is not only true but but
multiple multiples of true just by poll
numbers he's not popular among young
people at all with all of that said he's
been the president that's changed the
evidence on the ground so I've said I'm
more likely to vote for him in 2020 then
I was in 2016 meaning the damage has
already done it's not like I can put the
genie back in the bottle on all of those
things and now it's the presidents of
the United States he's sitting in that
office versus Kamala Harris or Bernie
Sanders or Elizabeth Warren so where are
you leaning in 2020 are you more likely
to vote from in 2020 than you were in
yeah no I'll vote for him in 2020 for
the reasons that you gave barring some I
can't think of a scenario where I
wouldn't so I would say yeah I would
vote for him he's already there he's in
office as you said there isn't for me
the whole never Trump thing was that was
a something for the primaries when there
were 19 other options and I was saying
any of these people be better so let's
go with one of them but once you got to
the general it was a little bit less of
a there's less of a point to it and once
he's in office it's there's no play
right never trumpism never Trump for
that what does that even I don't know
what that means I still don't know what
that means right at this point so he's
already there so I'll certainly vote for
me he is of course he's better than than
what Camille Harris would be or god
forbid or any Corey book or any of these
people but you know it's not just a
pride thing I do think that as I said
that it's the people who were
criticizing Trump that never Trump
people it's not like they've been
totally proven wrong on everything they
haven't some of what they've said has
come to fruition and and as you point
out also there's the demographic thing
and so we still need don't even know
exactly the long term damages that we're
suffering right now okay let's continue
with the free association game of
Thrones satanic no you know I I I made
one attempt to watch it and in the very
first episode that I watched there was a
brother-sister having sexual relations a
kid was tossed out of a window an old
lady was set on fire I think that's part
of it and so I was just scandalized I
wasn't really scandal I was just I
thought you know I don't know if I need
this in my head and so I've been trying
more of an effort
in recent years to say to myself alright
do I really need that I need those
images do I need that stuff inside me is
this really gonna be edifying use of my
time and I know anytime bring that up
everyone laughs and says are you being a
Puritan but there-there is an issue
right there is that there is a moral
component to what we watch and to our
entertainment that we choose to consume
some people act like it's a totally
amoral arena and so to offer any
criticisms of that sort of stuff is
crazy and so I don't I don't see that
although I have I've only seen the one
incest episode of Game of Thrones it's
possible that it got a lot better and
has earned it well it turns into
actually you know a religious revival in
Episode two so you missed the entire
religion yeah of course you're right I
mean there's there's an enormous amount
of of terrible behavior in the series
and it is pornographic particularly the
first couple of seasons it sort of gets
better as it goes on with the
pornographic aspect it's not something
that I would have my kids watch my view
of it is that there is an element of
morality to it it does have their
there's a feel that the bad guys in the
end are going to pay a moral price but I
guess the question is what you intend on
getting out of your out of your
entertainment so I've been an advocate
for the series because good drama is
good drama just on an aesthetic level it
is it is well plotted there are
characters that you care about and root
for it's clever it's it's visually
appealing I'm not sure that it is
morally edifying but do you think that
it's possible for them to be stuff made
that is you know both not up to the
standards that you'd want to watch it
next to your priest or I'd want to watch
the next my rabbi but still portrays
moral imagery in the end for example
it's better than some of the other stuff
that's out there yeah oh yeah definitely
I'm not one of those Christians that
says you can only watch Christian movies
I think most Christian movies are
abysmal and I'm sure that Jesus doesn't
like them either but so I think that you
know my favorite show of all time is
Breaking Bad and that is not you know
exactly a Christian show but I think
it's a show that has a deep moral sense
and so
sort of a morality play about what
happens when someone you take this
decent guy but he makes one bad choice
and then it's team rolls from there and
so I think there's a lot to be gained
from from shows like that so I think you
could have shows and movies that deal
with really difficult things and have
some objection ulm aterial but in the
end you do gain something from watching
them my favorite movie is The Godfather
again I mean there's a lot of violence
and everything in that but it's the same
sort of story about sort of meditation
on evil in a way so so yeah maybe maybe
the game of Thrones is that I don't know
it sort of moves in that direction I
will say at the very beginning it's a
lot more nihilistic and then it seems to
have moved more in the traditional
immoral direction it's hard to make a TV
show that it's completely a nihilistic
is the truth because people just don't
resonate to narratives that are
completely nihilistic if it turns out
that all the good guys get killed and
all the bad guys win is that really a
show that anybody wants to watch or is
interested in watching probably not the
human the human heart sort of longs for
stories where people do get their just
desserts in the end even if along the
way some good people end up getting
destroyed so ok time for time for the
next round of free association
Michael Noel's I was gonna say good
Catholics not as good as me but he's you
know mediocre Catholic and mediocre
person I mean I think we can agree on on
that I mean Knowles's is a discredit to
the company and he's a screwball but I'm
it's not my free association I really
shouldn't be so he's just awful I mean
the fact is that Noel's has somehow been
able to make a career out of being a
complete empty vessel and it's it's
incredible to me and all the stuff where
he's not an empty vessel whenever he
talks about it I mean my goodness have
you heard them going out go on for like
an hour about Aquinas it's it's really
just it's it's pretty terrifying and
we've done entering the backstage and
it's not great I'll tell you the
entertainment value is not high well but
it's Catholic those I mean I'm you know
I have to I've got that connection at
least so I have to use part of the
Catholic team okay okay final free
association yoga I already used satanic
sigh that satanic will be my answer for
like everything is
you know I still believe I know your I
wrote an article as I'm sure you know uh
about yoga it appeared a website that I
added in fact right and and I still
believe that I was a totally right about
that
listen yoga is is if you talk to someone
who's Hindu and you asked them about
about yoga they're gonna they're going
to tell you that it's it's a spiritual
Hindu exercise and they don't understand
why all these Americans are doing it
it's cultural appropriation so really
part of my problem with it is cultural
appropriation I'm very concerned about
that and then also I think that of all
the ways to exercise if you're Christian
is Jewish so many different ways to
exercise you could do you know you could
do so many different things you go to a
gym and they're a million different
exercise machines why do you need to do
a Hindu spiritual ritual of all the
things in the world why that that's my
only question and I posed that question
and no one no one could answer it except
to say you're insane which I might be
but that doesn't make me wrong about
this so you're okay let's just be clear
you're okay with the physical motions
you're just not cool with thee with all
of the Hindu associations that listen I
think those physical if you even
accidentally do one of those physical
motions you could be entered by Satan
immediately so that's my belief on it
cuz no one knows I'm joking
that is the it it's the whole yoga thing
that I think is the problem but you know
if you're just doing some stretch I
think you'll probably be fine okay so
let's talk about the biggest problems
facing the country we've talked about
the decline in religion obviously what
do you think is the the number one issue
the pressing issue in the United States
right now well I I'm gonna give the
answer I always give which for me it is
it's the life issue for me it so that's
why I write about abortion 50 times a
week because I think that how are we
supposed to move on to other issues when
we haven't settled the basic question of
whether or not life is valuable and if
it even means anything or if it's worth
preserving so to me that's is it's a
two-fold issue it's number one you've
got the actual death toll which is
trumps any any other cause of death many
many full
but then also is the philosophical issue
of does life even matter if it does then
let's focus on if it doesn't then what
does any of this stuff matter let's just
go home and drink ourselves to death
right so and practically speaking I
would also put the the fact that we're
continuing to fund Planned Parenthood
500 million a year that were giving this
organization that kills three hundred
thirty thousand babies a year and the
fact that we're doing that even after
Republicans controlled the White House
in Congress for two years and that by
the way is one of the reasons why I
can't give Trump or any of these guys
anything close to an a-plus because it's
not just that they didn't defend it it's
that they didn't even try they weren't
worried about it and I don't know how
that is I don't know how people could
not be focused on this we are giving
half a billion dollars to a company that
directly kills you know several stadiums
worth of people every single year so to
me that's number one oh and your book
unholy trinity you talked about that is
one of the big three issues they were
worried about what and then you talked
about marriage and gender as the other
two if I'm not mistaken so so what do
you think is the future of marriage you
know a lot of us in the religious
community and just generally we're
worried about the impact of same-sex
marriage on American society I was more
worried about the government using
same-sex marriage as a club to beat
religious institutions into the ground
through anti-discrimination law which is
something we've obviously seen in
California we've seen it in Colorado
what was your big worry about same-sex
marriage and do you think it's been
realized or have you sort of come to the
conclusion that the government should
stay out of all of this where are you on
that as you know I certainly think that
there's probably no going back gay
marriage is here and just there's not
going to be any effort to get rid of it
so I've certainly accepted that reality
even if I don't like it but I do you
know you know in a perfect world I do
still maintain that that it's not that
gave marriage should have been illegal
it wasn't the issue no one was saying
let's make a laws declaring that you're
not allowed to get married when you're
homosexual the issue was what does the
government recognize marriage is being
you know what does the government
recognize marriage as a thing
if it does then what is that thing and I
do think it's important for the
government to recognize marriage and to
offer certain incentives for because
marriage is the foundation for
civilization because it's the foundation
for the family so that's why I still
believe that and as far as you know the
slippery slope of where we had and
actually I do think we see that slippery
slope happening there's this slope
you're talking about of now they're
using it to you know first they're going
to the private businesses and saying
yeah you know it yeah you can have your
freedom of religion but sort of you know
sometimes you can and so they're doing
that and we're gonna see that effort
continue and then eventually they will
get to the churches and the synagogues
they're gonna get to the houses of
worship and they're gonna say because if
the problem is that they're saying gay
marriage is a human right which is what
the Supreme Court said it's a human
right okay if it's a human right
nobody's allowed to deny a human right
you can't a church can't deny a human
right it's not like a church can say oh
in our religion we have slavery so we're
gonna keep slaves in the basement
obviously you can't do that no one is
allowed to deny human rights so based on
that premise they've already set the
stage to be able to go to churches and
say if someone wants to get married in
your church you have to let them because
they're denying them you come in right I
mean this was my great fear obviously
about the oberfeld decision and also
about the legalization of same-sex
marriage or enshrinement of it in law as
a general rule my feeling was that we'd
be better off as religious people having
a strict separation between the state
and the marital issue entirely simply
because from my perspective you know I'm
an Orthodox Jew obviously I have to
marital documents one is the one that I
got from the state that I do not give
two damns about and then there's the one
that I have from my from the rabbinate
of Israel we were married in Israel
witnessed by two Sabbath observing Jews
that was the one that said I get to stop
my wife and live with her and have
babies right that was one I actually
care about I didn't care about the
secular one at all and by allowing the
state to redefine marriage what we're
really doing is that that was just the
capper on the decline of marriage that
had been occurring in the United States
and in the West for 50 60 years it
wasn't like same as people I think on
the right treated same-sex marriage as
though this is the this is what's going
to finally break marriage and I looked
at it and I thought
now this is just the capstone on a
system that's that's already broken that
once the social fabric was broken the
law was the last thing that was standing
and it was the last thing to sort of
fall away I know where you come down on
that yeah that well and the Liberals who
they had a really good point to make and
that was that well you know all you
people all you Christians that are
saying gay marriage is it's such a
terrible thing
well you allow divorces in your church I
mean you'll let a guy marry a woman on
your altar and then divorce that woman
and they marry another woman and another
woman so it's just essentially polygamy
by succession so you're already allowing
that what do you care you obviously
don't care about the sanctity of
marriage and that's and they're
absolutely right about that because a
lot of these people who cared about the
sanctity of marriage when it comes to
this really didn't care about it
especially when it came to their own
life you know when it was when they had
to make sacrifices and be faithful in
order to protect the sanctity of
marriage well then they don't really
care as much about it so that was a very
good point and I agree that a lot of
churches gave up on marriage essentially
in the mid 20th century when they
started allowing divorce and remarriage
which is but in the Bible
and the Gospels there really aren't a
lot of hot-button issues that Jesus
speaks about really directly and says
listen here's the deal with that thing
he doesn't do that very much
marriage is one of those things though
where he says very directly you if you
get divorced and remarry that's adultery
and that and that is recorded in
multiple Gospels him saying that so if
you can just ignore that and say yeah
you know no there's none of that he said
it that's one of the few issues where we
can look at what he said it's right
there
so if we're gonna punt that down the
road then how do you you know you've
already given up the defense's I mean it
seems to me that what happened from a
religious and from a secular perspective
is that the institution of marriage
which was always about the bearing and
rearing of children fundamentally
changed into it's two people who love
each other well once it's two people who
love each other you're at same-sex
marriage because it could be any two
people who love each other it has
nothing to do with kids anymore it has
nothing to do with building a functional
institution with a religious goal it has
nothing to do with with enshrining a
standard for the community if
it is is two people who love each other
living together then it could be any two
people who live together and there
there's no there's not even a limiting
principle with regard to siblings or
with regard to anybody else were seven
people right exactly I mean I'm frankly
confuse been confused by the leftist
argument that that two person marriage
is okay so long as it's same-sex
marriage but sibling marriage so long as
they're not having kids is bad or the
polygamy is bad I think that standard is
gonna fall in the next few years yeah
and I don't even and when people say
well it's slippery slippery slope next
thing we're gonna have polygamy oh I
actually think that you know if we're on
a slope gay marriage is like down here
in the slope polygamy was up here we
just kind of hopped over it there was
like a ramp on the slope in a slippery
slope argument a slippery slope argument
suggests that one thing happens that
leads to another thing it's just a
principle argument once you define a
principle there are certain things that
fall within that principle if it's two
people who love each other then you've
defined the principle there's a lot of
stuff that falls within that and if it's
just a group of people or any number of
people who love each other well then you
define that principle yeah I think that
uh there's a great GK Chesterton
quote where he talks about you know if
you're walking down the road and you see
a gate offense you're gonna want to know
why that fence is there before you
decide that hammers gonna tear this
fence down and so the problem is that we
started tearing down these lines of
distinction these fences without having
any understanding about why they were
actually there and so the left when it
came to gay marriage they said oh you're
trying to stop people and people from
loving each other you're being a bigot
it's like no that's that you don't have
to agree with us but that is not our
point that is not the point that we're
making here and so you just tore this
thing down without even understanding
why it existed in the first place and
that's pretty concerning considering
this thing that we're talking about is
one of the fundamental human
institutions
so once you've torn down those barriers
then right there's really no argument to
be made against any certainly any form
of human coupling I just don't see what
basis we would objective it well
speaking of tearing down fences without
any sort of regard for what comes next
obviously we're in the middle of a wild
rethink in the West about the nature of
gender the attempt to separate off
gender from sex the attempt to suggest
that you can be any gender you want to
be and that
you don't have to be a biological woman
to be a woman or you don't have to be a
biological man to be a man where do you
think what do you think the end goal of
this isn't do you think that this is a
battle that the left is going to win
because obviously they won the same sex
marriage battle do you think that
they're going to win the redefinition of
sex battle as well certainly if they win
it then and I know these kind of
statements are made all the time and
it's it's overdone but in this case I
think we could say if they win that
battle then it really is over a Western
civilization is over at that point if
they're able to do that then what else
is there because what they've done there
is they have they have this is this is
why I think they care so much about the
issue is that this is all about
relativism everything's about relativism
for them it's all about it's my truth my
this is my truth this is what I believe
this is good for me and so this is sort
of the ultimate peak to climb that's
sort of the ultimate relativistic peak
where if you're even if you're even able
to do that with your own biological
identity where I can say no no I'm not
this I'm gonna be something else and if
we've decided that's okay well then it's
it's just it's game on we live in a
relativistic society and that's why I
think we need to pay very close
attention to the change that's happened
even in the last year or so where
originally they said that well you've
got sex and gender and gender is a
social construct sex is biological and
you can be whatever gender you want that
was the original argument right if
you've noticed recently now they're
saying that no biological sex is also it
can be whatever you want there it's the
same thing that they've now they
originally created this false
distinction and now they've merged them
back in and they moved gender over into
being this sort of social construct and
now they've recup 'old them but they've
done it over here in the social
construct area so I think we need that's
that's a pretty big development and I
think on transgenderism like on every
other issue the conservative movement
was very slow in picking up on it in
fact when I wrote the book about
transgenders and I started writing that
book I don't know four years ago and and
I was talking about publisher about it
and they said you know but
transgenderism is that kind of a fad are
people really gonna be talking about it
a year from now
and I think that was the attitude a lot
of people had they thought that mess
it's not a big deal but it's not going
anywhere that's for sure yeah well I
mean the attempt to take what is a very
fringe issue statistically speaking and
then make it central to the American
public discourse in the Western public
discourse it doesn't really have much to
do with sympathy for the people who are
suffering from gender identity disorder
or gender dysphoria it seems to me it
has much more to do with redefining not
only sex itself but redefining the
nature of reason so if you even attempt
to use reason and fact then you are
deemed a bigot and that's part of a
broader agenda which is to link politics
with identity if I disagree with you
politically it's an attack on your
identity and therefore you can be
silenced because you're actually acting
in vicious fashion by citing facts in
the first place that that to me is is
the real danger in all this there are a
couple of dangers that I see one is the
attempt that I see coming to take
children out of the homes of people who
refuse to abide by the new dictates of
the social Left that if you have a
seven-year-old who is expressing some
sort of confusion about their sex that
if you don't kowtow to what the
authorities would have you do they will
remove the kid from your home they'll
take the kid away and say that you're
being cruel you've already seen this
happening in Britain I I think that that
is obviously one move but the the
broader move is to redefine the nature
of even how we argue how we discuss
these things with each other because if
you say you know a man is a man and a
woman is woman you'll get banned from
Twitter now I mean they have literally
banned feminists for doing exactly this
yeah and that's why I think the whole
pronoun thing it's it's actually it's
not semantics it's a really important it
is it is a hill worth dying on because
they're trying to redefine the language
and they're saying what's it to you if
someone says that they want you to refer
to them as she when it's really a he
well because it's not true
that's why I'm not gonna do it there's
nothing against that person I've got all
the sympathy in the world for them but
I'm not gonna lie for you and that and
that is just a lie and I won't
participate in it and when we allow the
left to not only you know they've been
doing it for a long time where they come
up with these euphemisms and they
require us to use them and a lot of the
time we do use them for some reason but
in this case they're saying that no
you're you have to lie when you speak
about this and I think we need to draw
the line there and say absolutely not so
what's your personal view on this so my
view
is that publicly when I'm speaking about
this issue I refuse to use arbitrary
pronouns I use biological pronouns if
her out to dinner with somebody who are
transgender I'm not gonna go out of my
way to alienate the person by calling
them something they don't want to be
called because who cares I mean I'm out
to dinner with the person the goal of
the dinner is not to insult the person
but in public view when the issue at
issue is this then I'm only going to use
the the factually correct pronouns where
do you stand on this I think it's very
it's similar to what I say about the
abortion argument which is when we're
talking about abortion in the public
arena I think we need to use phrases
like baby killing because that's what it
is and people need to understand that
but if I were talking 101 to a woman who
just had an abortion or who was
considering one I would not say I
wouldn't call our baby killer and I
wouldn't use phrases like that because I
think on a one-on-one level it requires
a little bit more understanding and
sympathy and the last thing that person
needs is fear and because that's what
they're getting from the clinics anyway
so it's a similar thing with this issue
where yeah on a public level we draw a
hard line if I'm talking to someone
one-on-one I still am NOT gonna use the
incorrect pronouns but I'll probably do
my best to just say yeah usually when
you're talking someone I want you have
to use their pronouns anyway so that
would be the effort that all that I'll
make but push comes to shove even
one-on-one I'm not gonna lie to somebody
or at least I would hope that I wouldn't
okay so let's talk about Pope Francis
for a second so I will admit I was a
much bigger fan of Pope John Paul the
second I was a much bigger fan of Pope
Benedict I am NOT a fan of this
particular Pope but I'm an outsider
obviously I'm not part of the church
what's your take on Pope Francis yeah I
agree with you I think that's a view
that the most conservative Catholics
have is we would we would love to have
either one of those two back but when
Francis first came onto the scene I
thought that he was you know wasn't my
first choice but it's not my decision
anyway and and there were certain things
about him the whole thing I said he's so
humble and I've come to believe that
some of that is really just stick
honestly but at the time I thought okay
but over time as you see this sort of
side of Francis where there appears to
really be
it's not just that he disagrees with
conservative Catholics on a lot of
issues which he does which is concerning
enough because conservative Catholic is
just Catholic has just fun to find a
tional Catholic but there's also this
vindictive streak to him I think that he
really doesn't like conservative
Catholics and he says these things that
it made this scheme he's made comments
about Catholics that have a lot of kids
and comparing them to like rabbits and
stuff like that
she's pretty common you hear that out in
society but from the Pope saying stuff
like that so that's what I pick up from
is that it really doesn't like he
actually has a personal distaste for
conservative Catholics and what we need
in a pope is you know even aside from
the doctrinal issues which are so
important we also need a pope especially
these days in the church who is willing
to go into the Vatican and clean it out
and I'm not just talking about child
molesters obviously we need to get rid
of those but the bigger issue in the
church that few people want to talk
about is is the homosexuality in the
priesthood and and that's what a lot of
stuff is even these sex scandals you
know McCarrick I mean note he was
accused of being with some young
children which is horrible
most of the accusations though had to do
with him and seminarians or grown adult
men so what we needed a pope is someone
who's gonna go in and address that issue
and and Francis just is not willing to
do that famously he said Who am I to
judge which again here that in society
I'm used to hearing that in society
hearing that from a Pope is very
concerning
so as a Catholic how do you deal with
the sort of cognitive dissonance of
having a pope who you feel isn't really
doing what he should be doing well I
remind myself that in the Gospels even
Peters the first pope he denied Christ
three times I mean Christ chose twelve
apostles one betrayed him one denied him
the rest of man admit the cross except
for one so you know it's a pretty low
batting average already even from the
very beginning and and so you know the
church is I believe a divinely
established institution but it is an
institution comprised of human beings
who are all very flawed and so that
doesn't really share
my my faith and any because I never
expected perfection from from them do
you think that the the church how could
the church be doing a better job of
dealing with the the sex scandals
generally sort of referred to it
tangentially there but let's say that
you're suddenly elected pope it was pope
matt the first so what what exactly i
don't know what name you would take but
i some wouldn't maybe it would be I mean
Matthew works but I mean what what would
you do if you were in charge of the
church first thing I would do is bring
back the Inquisition well then I am yeah
why III think that the there have been
some measures that they've that they
have taken so it's not like they have
they've done nothing over the last
decade or so but I think that we have to
realize where the problem predominantly
is and that is not not just with
pedophilia which is a which is an issue
but statistically a smaller issue the
greater issue is just sort of sexual
indiscretion of all different kinds in
the priesthood there's it's sort of like
a sexual anarchy it seems like in the
priesthood even though a lot of it is
legal what they're doing you know
according to the laws of man so there
needs to be a I think a a refocus on
chastity and sexual morality and if
you've got priests who don't appear to
be buying into that and don't really
love the church and don't love their
faith it's pretty obvious you can you
can kind of point those guys out I you
know I've been to churches with those
kinds of priests you can tell from a
mile away then you've got to start
weeding those priests out I think that
the church is reluctant to do that for a
number of reasons not the least of which
being that there's a also a crisis of
vocations right now where there aren't a
lot of young men trying to be priests so
they figure well if we start getting rid
of all these guys there's not gonna be
anyone around to run the churches and so
it is a problem but you know what I
would rather have that I would rather
have churches shutting down I would
rather have a church that becomes
condensed and and and much smaller but
what you have left with the remnants are
people who are really on fire with the
faith really believe in it sort of the
church militant and so I say
that's fine let's trim the fat and if
you got to shut down churches and that
means that the parishioners in that went
to that church now have to drive 45
minutes if they're not willing to do
that then okay and it's not that
important to them clearly so maybe
that's what we need you know so let's
talk about American conservatism for a
second so obviously we talked a little
earlier about president Trump and the
sort of redefinition of the Republican
Party where do you see American
conservatism right now is it a movement
does it exist what are the core tenets
and where do you see it going in the in
the future it's hard for me to call it a
movement because I have no idea where
it's moving to and and I don't think
that anyone knows what conservatism is I
can't can you define it I don't know if
I were to say you get a hundred
conservatives in a room what do all what
do most of these people fundamentally
believe in I'm not sure that you'll find
any real agreement maybe on a few issues
okay so they'll all believe in gun
rights which is great they'll probably
all be against the illegal immigration
fine I think it's kind of it those those
those are the issues that we all agree
on which are important but they're not
foundational you can't build a movement
on that that's that's that's sort of a
niche that's a that's a sort of a
separate movement that branches off of
the main one and you need that you know
you need the kind of specialists who
really are focused on the border or gun
rights the problem in conservatism is
that we don't have the foundational
agreement about what our what we
actually believe so I would say the
conservatism essentially doesn't exist
so do you see any political leaders
obviously or not a huge Trump fan do you
see any political leaders who sort of
are people who you would like to see in
positions of power I hate all of them I
don't my first reaction to any
politician is just to hate them by
default and then so they're already in
the doghouse with me and now you have to
prove to me that you deserve to come out
of the doghouse and I think that's the
attitude we should all have to
politicians you know it's it's not
healthy I've gone about this all the
time you should never be a fan of a
politician you know be a fan of a pop
star or a athlete not a politician these
are people that we should be skeptical
of and we should have always be looking
sort of have given the side-eye to
looking at what they're doing
so a politician that I really like you
know I guys like Ted Cruz I mean I liked
him in 2016
Mike Lee and you know these these kind
of classic conservatives who are also
social conservative so I like them I
don't know that though that these are
the guys who can reignite the movement
so is there a guy like that maybe I just
don't know who I mean I'm not sure that
there is a politician who comes to mind
there politicians who I like but I think
the rule of politicians is that they
either die a hero or they live long
enough to become the villain is is
typically the theme of for politicians
there are people I like right now but
they haven't held tremendous power or
been in a competitive race where they
have to start pandering in the middle of
the race to to people who I think they
ought not be pandering to so yeah the
problem the problem with politicians is
that they became a politician because
they want that job and so anyone who
wants that job you automatically have to
be skeptical of because why would you
want to do this it was jr. our token who
said something like you know bossing
other men is the most unnatural job in
the world very few people are fit for at
least of all the people who actually
apply for the job and so that's kind of
the way that I that I look at it as well
I think that you could sometimes have a
politician who gets into it because they
really have a passion for public service
and they want to lead and they love
America and every once in a while you
have that benevolent sort of figure we
have none of those right now
so the second best option is someone
who's obviously self-interested
obviously focused on their own
advancement but they also happen to have
some good and useful qualities and they
they're good on the issues and they have
some integrity so that's sort of that's
what we're looking for is that second
best option and that is right now so
let's talk for a second about college so
you've seen in the past few weeks these
scandals unfolding with parents paying
exorbitant feast yet their kids into
colleges like USC which like I'm a UCLA
guy but also $500,000 to get into USC
that is not a bargain by any stretch of
the imagination
that's a $200 cheeseburger no offense to
USA but come on guys you didn't go to
college
I obviously love a happy well-rounded
life I mean you have a
good income what's your recommendation
to people who are in high school should
they be shooting for college is college
useful where do you think it's useful
and where is it not I think it's sort of
simple and that is if you're getting out
of high school and you know exactly what
you want to do with your life and you
know that you need college for that
thing if you want to be a doctor an
engineer architect something like that
and yeah absolutely go to college and
it'll be worth it if you know that you
you want to do something being mechanic
something like that where you you're not
going to need that then obviously don't
go or go to a trade school that's
obvious enough most kids I think fall in
the middle category which is they have
no idea at the age of 18 what they want
to do which is partly natural at that
young age also it's because the public
schools do a terrible job of actually
helping kids explore their passions and
skills and interests so you've got a
bunch of kids that are coming out of
high school and saying I have no clue
what I want to do if you're in that
category then here's here's what I
recommend don't go right away there's no
you don't there's no reason there's no
good reason to go sign on the dotted
line sign yourself up for decades of
debt and then go to this institution get
the degree pay a hundred thousand
dollars for a piece of paper hoping
you'll figure out what to do with it
don't do that um go live your life for a
few years go go get a job you know get
an apartment save some money you know
just just experiment with figuring out
what it is that you're good at and what
you want to do and then if you discover
down the line that you're really
passionate about something where the
college degree is necessary then go it's
just I just don't understand why why did
we get in this thing where you have to
go in you're 18 if someone goes when
they're 22 what does that matter it's
not a race who are you racing you know
it's it's it's you've got a long life
ahead of you or you don't you're gonna
die young doesn't matter anyway okay so
in one second I want to ask you our
final question and that is you got kids
so what do you do as you're trying to
pair your kids for a world that
inevitably seems to be falling apart you
have any reading recommendations what
are your big parenting tips so I'm gonna
ask Matt that question but if you want
to hear Matt Walsh's answer you have to
be a daily water subscriber subscribe
head on over to daily we're calm click
Subscribe is that simple you can hear
the end of our conversation well Matt
Walsh of The Daily wire thanks so much
for stopping by I really appreciate it I
mean we you had to I mean you really
didn't have a choice about it but now
that you're here thanks for coming
good to see you first
[Music]
avenge Shakira shows Sunday special is
produced by Jonathan hey executive
producer Jeremy boring associate
producer Mathis Kluber edited by Donovan
Fowler audio is mixed by Dylan Kate's
hair and makeup is by Joshua alvera
title graphics by Cynthia and Guillot
the Ben Shapiro shows Sunday special is
a daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 19
[Music]